have you ever dated a
coworker not
dated we've done
stuff oh do you frequent any of the
office happy hours oh like everyone yes
amazing okay perfect you guys know you
all know for sure craziest place you've
had sex so one was a lake one was a
stairwell and then another one was just
like during a party which like stairwell
and party same day tell me
one of your recent fantasies sexual
fantasies I do have like a little Kink
where I like to do it like anywhere
where do you think would be the best
place to have sex in an office I think
also a stairwell we had a little fire
safety day and I was like oh that's okay
taking notes
interesting it's not Diana have you had
sex in an office no I have not ah